hello and welcome to world stories your
international reporters magazine
i'm sarah harman this week we travel to
cairo
to check in with an entrepreneur in
post-revolution egypt
and we'll tell you all about how a
railway in moldova
is threatening an entire ecosystem but
first we head to india
some 4 million air conditioning units
are sold every year in that country
but the refrigerants in them are often
harmful to the planet
so one conditioner manufacturer in
mumbai is trying to convince customers
that investing in more
eco-friendly units pays off for them as
well as for the environment
is this the air conditioning of the
future both geppard reports
a summer's day in mumbai it's hot far
above 35 degrees celsius
anyone with a day off is at juhu beach
cooling down
as far as that's possible
shashikan choudhary just has a short
break
he runs a popular snack bar now he's
gone home for a quick lunch
the chowdhrys belong to india's middle
class
the fan that just circulates the hot air
is no longer good enough for them
now they want an air conditioner
it's true that air conditioners are
expensive
but we're going to buy one anyway just
because it's so hot
i can't concentrate on the studies
because of heat
so we need easy
about 4 million air conditioners are
sold every year in india
the refrigerants in them are extremely
bad for the climate
like in most air conditioning units
worldwide
the harmful gases often escape into the
atmosphere through leaks in the
appliances
200 kilometers southeast of mumbai since
april 2012
the indian company godrej has been
making air conditioners
that are better for the environment
they're 600 percent less damaging to the
climate
than conventional units in air
conditioner manufacturing that amounts
to a revolution
about a million euros for the
manufacturing plant came from the german
environment ministry
godrej itself invested about half that
amount
the carbon emissions the consumer saves
with this
unit are equivalent to the entire amount
of carbon emitted by your average
german car in a year
there's a disadvantage the refrigerant
used
is propane a highly flammable gas
using it requires high safety standards
we use a very small quantity of charge
of the refrigerant in the
unit we're using only 350 to 370 grams
which is safe for room size of about 150
square feet
which is what this unit is meant for so
even if this entire charge leaks out
into the room
it would not cause a flammable mixture
with the air inside the room
the cartridge company wants to break
into a market that many other
manufacturers have already cornered
the competition is tough even though the
market is growing steadily
company headquarters in mumbai the
family-owned business is over a hundred
years old
anyone who wants an affordable
refrigerator or washing machine
buys from godrej at least that used to
be the case
but in the past few years the company
has lost market share
with its green air conditioners it hopes
to attract more customers again
for this to work the marketing strategy
has to be just right
video clips emphasize the products
climate credentials
but they're only shown in shops
in its television commercials godrej is
focusing on energy efficiency
the new air conditioner uses over 20
percent
less electricity than the others
a lot of us personally liked the green
approach a lot more
but when we went to consumers we found
that the green approach was not
what worked for them primarily they were
looking for energy efficiency
and value for money for themselves and
if they were getting that and green was
additional to that then that was great
the chaudris did some comparison
shopping
but in the end they opted for the godrej
product
even though it cost about 10 percent
more than the competition
they explained how it works you only
have to fill it once
the electricity costs are lower and it's
environmentally friendly as well
this unit has just come out
i've only sold two in two weeks but i
think it will establish itself on the
market
later it will pick up pick up the market
a strategy meeting at godrej marcus
vubia from the german agency for
international cooperation the giz
explains what's required to get a german
eco label a good selling point on the
indian market
in principle this product actually would
also
help the european market to reduce
greenhouse gas emissions
we would like to go into other
international markets obviously
but establish ourselves establish the
technology well
make sure that all the safety
requirements are taken care of then
obviously go forward
in neighboring countries it will
probably be relatively
easy to get established but if they want
to break into the european market
they'll have to fulfill slightly higher
standards
but first their target is the indian
market
the chowdhurys are proud owners of one
of the 1000 odd climate friendly units
sold
so far the installers have been
specially trained by godrej
to make sure not an iota of flammable
propane
can escape
finally the long-awaited moment arrives
and shashikan chowdhury thinks it's just
cool the environment
is also a concern in southern moldova
there the lower proofed floodplain is
home to such rich biodiversity
that it prompted the creation of a
natural park
but then a railway was constructed
through the region the promise was to
promote economic development
but the local flora and fauna are
suffering what's more
locals say they haven't benefited from
the new infrastructure either
lucia thought from trm moldova has that
story
the lower fruit is a scientific reserve
located in the south of the republic of
moldova
many species of migratory birds come
here to breed
the reserve was created to protect the
flora and fauna of the lakes and swamps
around the river fruit
in 2007 a railway was built in this area
to transport goods to the international
port of giorgio leste
the construction project violates
several european conventions designed to
protect the ecosystem
which moldova has ratified
at that time we were particularly
concerned about the fact
that this railway was built without
taking into account
national laws and international
conventions
we said it then and repeat today that
this embankment was built on marshy
ground
so there's no connection to the bedrock
this is not a stable embankment
officially the controversial railway
line was intended to shore up moldova's
economy
however locals see the project as a
blatant attempt to launder money
they say that their environment and
their lives are being restricted by the
railway
a fortress dating back to the dachshund
era used to stand here
railway construction destroyed those
traces
we asked for the government to protect
land use for crop rotation
and to plant trees in the area
many plants that are at risk of
extinction can still be found in this
region
a large number of them are listed in the
red book moldova's endangered species
list
the area is also very important for
migratory birds
in summer there are sometimes even
pelicans a threatened species in europe
the we have seven species of plants
included in the red book here the white
water lily
the water arrow and wild vines for
instance
and we usually have the common pelican
that comes from the danube delta
from june until mid-july
this year though there was much less
water in bellaiu
in some summers the belaiu lake loses
around half of its fresh water
the railway embankment has only served
to exacerbate this harmful phenomenon
if the trend continues this beautiful
landscape could soon look
very different
now to egypt the country has been in
political upheaval
for the past two and a half years and
all the unrest has been
bad news for the economy the tourism
industry has slumped
and the state's finances are crumbling
now imagine trying to expand your
business amid that turmoil
waheed al-mala from emerging stars tv
introduces us to a young entrepreneur
who is doing
just that and business is booming
let's meet the man who's bringing fresh
bread to cairo
you can see smell even you can hear the
crust
happening in front of you in the oven so
tbs is all about
freshness this could definitely be
called a fresh idea
opening a chain of shops offering fresh
oven-baked bread
a new concept in egypt we visit tbs
the bakery shop and meet one of the
founders
basel mashua he tells us about the
company
and the concept they introduced we have
the
so fresh it's baked in front of you
concept so this is what makes
tbs have a competitive edge versus any
bakery in the market and we simply
thought about this
concept to fill a gap in the market we
were exposed to the
international market whenever we travel
we find good bakeries good smell
walking down the street so we thought
why not
have such a concept in egypt and this is
where it all came from
three young entrepreneurs started the
bakery shop in 2008
none of them knew anything about baking
bread but they were convinced the
egyptian market was ready for freshly
baked products
in the beginning it was a sideline next
to their day jobs
this was pretty hectic because i had to
go and to my working hours from nine to
five
and then i had to manage everything that
had to do with tbs
afterwards so it was a very hectic but i
think this was the safest bet
it was too much risk to drop your
current
job just to for a dream right
the tbs bakery shop is the flagship of
the company
however in order to grow the business
they started offering a wider range of
services
well currently the the company name is
delicious bakery it has
three revenue streams one is tbs the
premium brand
with eight shops and then we have the
shop and shop model under the delicious
bakery name
which is in supermarkets it's seven
shops and then we have the b2b line
which we cater to all the cafes and
restaurants
in each but growing the business also
brings challenges
especially if you want to maintain
quality standards in all the shops
the most difficult thing is the
consistency because the consistency is
the name of the game in our
industry the more we grow and we more
the more we open outlets it gets
more difficult to maintain the the
quality and the
consistency of the product
well first of all uh centralizing the
production was one of the
ways to to to to control this
consistency problem
uh now we have uh
like production manuals where where
where the new employees get
like a month or two months training to
to to to to get trained on exactly the
the shape of the
bread where we want for example if you
can if you can see this low for this
loaf
when you visit any of the tbs outlets
you'll find the the loaf looking exactly
the same because
this is what we want we we're a chain
we're getting bigger
so whenever there's a customer going to
any of our tbs outlets
he has to find the exact same product
currently tbs has eight shops throughout
egypt
managing this is time consuming but
basel mature makes sure he's got enough
time available for his family if
the entrepreneur doesn't see his kids
then it's his problem
because i think you always have to
manage your time to
balance between your work and and your
kids
because what good will it make if you're
making money without
knowing your kids quite well so i guess
i enjoy
my kid every day
right i think we are the new generation
especially after the revolution we are
the generation that
i think would make a difference in in
the next years to come
we really depend on ourselves to make
this country head for a better future a
brighter future
so of course i i think we are the
generation to come
and it's up to us to shape the future of
this country
basel also makes sure he has time for
sports
he used to be a professional water polo
player
and was part of the 2004 egyptian
olympic team
sports and business have much in common
he explains
of course there is a lot of similarities
it's
uh it's more all around it's more
revolving around the fact
having a challenge and running after
this challenge it's both in sports and
in
your business also you learn to be
working within a team teamwork is
something that we really
got exposed to dealing with the water
polo
and now again i have to deal with a
whole
but a bigger team also discipline
is something that you learn in sports
being a member of
a big team and again you have to
maintain this
in your home business we return to the
bakery
where basel tells us about the future
plans of tbs
in 10 years i guess we'll be expanding
tbs
to around 20 shops supermarket we have
unlimited expansions and the b2b the
more concepts opens in egypt the more we
get more business and
for tbs
i know where i'll be dropping in for a
croissant the next time i'm in cairo
and speaking of traveling are you the
kind of tourist who'd rather experience
local culture and art than party all
night on the beach
if so this next report might be
something for you
it comes to us from central mexico far
off the beaten track
miriam cortez from tdt mexico takes us
to a small town with a hidden treasure
one that locals are hoping they can soon
open up and share with the rest of the
world
have a look
klaxco a small city in central mexico
offers traditional mexican charms and a
history dating back
thousands of years
la penuela is one of the highest
mountains in the district and greets
visitors with stunning panoramas
and fresh mountain air a welcome reward
after a difficult climb
we've come to see some of la penuela's
hidden corners
on the way we visited a cave that is
located deep in the pena bendita
mountain
in de la rosa it's on ricardo martinez's
private property
so he showed us around and let us admire
the brightly colored rocks
we even saw a few bats
then we climbed another 300 meters to
reach our final destination
a cave adorned with ancient rock
paintings created by some of the
region's
original inhabitants
vicente rodriguez says the paintings
have many similarities with
other famous archaeological sites like
chauvet cave in france
he says they're among the oldest in the
world
they were painted in about 10 000 bc
by tribes who moved around this area
while many of the paintings have faded
over the centuries
they still possess invaluable cultural
significance
they're an expression of the
spirituality that shaped the lives of
mexico's first
peoples human figures can be seen among
the images of dogs and other animals
as well as abstract shapes and patterns
the paints that were used were all
natural for example
coal mud or even animal fat
60 pigments have been found in the
district of tlatsko 39 in la cienega
8 in la palma 12 in rosario
and 2 in mesas the mexican national
institute of anthropology and history
has catalogued
and analyzed the rock paintings
it's calling on mexican authorities to
protect the paintings which have been
damaged over time
the cave's owner ricardo martinez plans
to set up an
information stand so that the public
will be able to visit these caves
in the future
digital photography is changing the way
people preserve their memories
and it's also changing how much they're
willing to pay for those memories
in hanoi freelance photographers are
finding many people
no longer want to make an appointment
and pose for portraits
when they could just snap selfies with
their smartphone
ho tv in vietnam reports on a dying
trade
every weekend 80-year-old freelance
photographer che winn
rides to the capitol's botanical gardens
to work
some 15 years ago he would not have been
alone
nowadays he says it's almost impossible
to make a living from freelance
photography
as customers willing to pay for
professional portraits are dwindling
in the past there were many freelance
photographers here
at that time photographers could make
enough money
to even buy a house in hanoi
these days people have their own cameras
they're light and easy to use
the digital photography revolution has
made hanoi's freelance photographers
almost obsolete
i have a smartphone and a digital camera
so it's easy and convenient to take
pictures of my friends and family
hiring a photographer is very time
consuming because you have to wait for
them to print the photos
digital photography has allowed people
to gain better knowledge of the craft
and help them develop more discerning
tastes
a freelance photographer can't keep up
with us
and besides the quality of freelance
photographers varies quite a bit
has spent around 20 years taking photos
at honkem lake
he used to take hundreds of pictures for
customers now he's lucky if he gets a
dozen orders
he also runs a photography club with
about 25 members
but there used to be twice as many
we advise younger photographers to see
freelance photography only as a way of
making a bit of extra money
on top of a full-time job
most don't know what to do
with so many amateur photographers
around these days hanoi's freelance
street photographers fear they will soon
be a thing of the past
that's all for this edition of world
stories from all of us here in berlin
and our partner stations around the
world thanks for tuning in
to watch this episode and others head to
our website the address there
d w dot d e world stories before we go
check out this week's picks of the world
enjoy and see you next time
so
you